I was shocked on the wrap-up show
yesterday JD said he was in drama club I
can't even believe drama club yeah
drama club I mean there's a guy who's so
inhibited I never could have been was he
in school plays yeah that's not possible
hey where is that clip guys sorry George
what I think that's possible I was a
member of the no no JD you know I do
I've seen when you talked about his
first sexual experience yeah but you see
how inarticulate he is yeah and
uncomfortable those are sometimes
surprising actors when you give him a
script and a character to play well I
would be surprised to be an actor you
gotta be able to talk well actually my
nickname in high school was cheesy why
was it she why cheesy I was in drama in
high school yes you were and I actually
was the lead in the senior play get
smart we were in we were in you know
rehearsal one day for the play and this
you know this girl said something and
and then I said something that was
mildly humorous or whatever and then the
girl said you know oh that's so cheesy
and I said well it's not easy you are a
master communicator you really I was I
can't believe in high school there was a
play about Get Smart
yeah we did a play about mash I was try
for Jon you and you were Maxwell Smart
he's one of my favorite characters Donna
but what could you do hello this is my I
actually didn't do like I'm that I
didn't do a whatever that guy's let me
hear you be Maxwell Smart I didn't watch
the show for research you know if I do
JD is Maxwell Smart can you imagine what
that sounds like
however Jubilee
I did you say hello chief
I think so bye you know I wasn't i I
didn't do that guy's impression right
you did your own Maxwell Smart sound
like his Maxwell Smart
hello chief James Cole was you the
character that you did I don't remember
any of the lines
here you do and what and your nickname
was cheesy because this show was cheesy
no he said something cheesy yeah and
then I said it's not easy being cheesy
and then that stock yeah we heard that
story
and then she said to me name is cheesy
do you remember how you prepared for
that character well I didn't really
prepare wasn't I'm not some master
thespian I'm kidding I just my big thing
was remembering the lines was everybody
just awful in your high school what do
you think if he was the star the guy
can't even speak English